today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza if you were wondering
if you can have something in your mouth
that feels like it's from another
country you can Italy and that is pizza
gray block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard on
the way to the beach gray block get that
header today's guest is a he's a film
man and he's a comedian and honestly I
don't even really know him that well
so I'm gonna get to know him as you do
but I do know that he is the star of the
emoji movie TJ Miller
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it is you know what and I just
sometime I like to have something
sometimes I'll work some glasses that
don't have any lenses or just something
I don't really like interview and so it
makes me feel are not interviewing but
sometimes I'm just not it's not really
my strongest suit so you think yeah well
one of the things is you riff on your
own and with the voicemails and stuff
like that so yeah you know it's and it's
that's closer to stand up right when
doing an interview and then I find that
other people are almost more comfortable
interviewing like that's one thing that
I've thought is really interesting about
I mean the joke with Marc Maron's
podcast was always like fast forward
through his part and get to the
interview cuz he's such a good
interviewer yeah and then Joe Rogan I
think has slowly become more about the
interview and being the interviewer then
about it being comedic I don't want
anything that yeah he's yeah he's not
usually suit he's not very comedic or
was some guess he is and some guess he
isn't yeah but I didn't give you
interviews really well but that's
interesting that you don't feel
necessarily comfortable doing that
because we were talking about I have the
show called Gore burger where it's a
giant blue alien puppet that interviews
people and that was on Comedy Central
and there's a lot of it on YouTube and
that I felt really good and I'm I was
interested in interviewing it and he did
Gore burger did Snoop Dogg's GGN Network
and it was just an it's a real burger
it's a fake burger but it's uh no it's
like oh there it is that's it oh wow
yeah he's and so it's a giant puppet and
there's somebody else in the puppet is
it you but I'm so I'm controlling his
mouth using a radio controller and two
other puppeteers are doing his eyes and
sort of facial expressions
mhm and so it's a lot it's like Joe
Biden you mean a little a little bit
less well that's incredible looking it's
great and so I do
these two guys the director brothers and
it say it feels a lot more comfortable
for me kind of what you're saying to
interview somebody through the character
because he's are talks like this and he
doesn't really know anything about human
beings and so he has kind of questions
about what it's like to be a human yeah
so the questions can kind of come from
that angle instead of necessarily being
you know TJ Miller asking questions yeah
so yeah I really really like that and
then my podcast caching him with TJ
Miller is the conceit is that cash levy
he's a comedian and an improviser a
friend of mine and I tour with he has an
interview show but he can never get
another guest so I've been his only
guest for like six years then oh really
so the interview and he you know hit
every time yeah every single time but
it's it's more absurdists and it's kind
of you know the interviews aren't about
you know what's what are you up to
what's going on with you it's more stuff
like you know we have a thing where it's
like if you attach a handle to anything
does it become a ladle like if you put
this just immediately become a ladle
committin like right now the mitten
would be a ladle that's exactly right
that would be a better is that a better
ladle than a glove mmm or can you use
each of the fingers for the separate
things that you want to ladle I think
glove probably be better because a
mitten is gonna have too much liquid he
could get out of a mitten yeah I've kind
of run water across the house and a
mitten when I was young and it's it's
answer I'd love to know with the context
of that is just not having a car yes you
just gotta get that water one way or
another no kidding you're being fast
yeah yeah doesn't matter
well can you relate you think too that
Ana like do you feel like you sometimes
like because I feel like you to me like
cuz we don't know each other that well
yeah I know we kind of have crossed
paths mostly through stand-up yeah yeah
yeah do you feel like and you always
seem to me like um like I always tell
know that someone with y'all obviously
cuz I always felt like there was like a
fire alarm going off or something
sometimes like I get that's the same
kind of feeling I guess sometimes like
me yeah not good I'm you are that's
insane
I like daddy behind your something
pulled a fire alarm or maybe even you
just pulled it on your own back and it's
just like there's like there is that
energy I've never heard anything even
close to that but that's pretty right on
and sometimes it's the energy of me
coming in I live in New York now so and
in in Manhattan I do and it's a much
better speed for me because all right
yeah in Greenwich Village and then I'll
zip around to do three four five sets in
a night and that is a better energy for
me to just like run from the subway to
the club go right up do the set you like
get paid talk to the people then leave
run to the subway get on a subway get
out of the go to different that's kind
of I feel more comfortable in that
energy and I think that was always a
problem for me in Los Angeles was that I
had that energy but here it's a lot more
laid-back not just that Cali attitude
but also you know you do one show in a
night maybe two shows and if you're
gonna do - it's like a spot at The
Improv and you'll make your way up to
Lau factory so there's no rush yeah
there's no newer energy like that and
then you can hustle it's more hype than
hustle yeah that's a good point there's
no racial energy yeah and so the hustle
energy with but that also works when you
do film and television especially
television because they are moving
quickly they need every you know minute
cost this amount of money and so they
appreciate that I'm like all right let's
go let's go and then I just riff like
you know five six lines okay is that
good let's do it all right let's get the
cameras in a different position and you
have moments of chilling and and
relaxing on a film set and sometimes
people say it's a lot of waiting but as
soon as the knock comes on the trailer
or you got to quickly get into it and go
and they need you on set right away and
you go in front of the camera and boom
you got to go but do you feel like I
like I feel like and I get I don't know
PIME not being judgmental Bob oh I
always feel like you're like it you
remind me of like a character like you
remind me of like uh it feels a little
judgmental doesn't yeah no no I think
that's right I mean here you ever feel
like that
now here's here's this sort of character
is like I think it's funny like you I
feel I feel like you're so town
- man I mean I think anytime I've ever
seen you perform I'm like I don't know
what is going on inside of this - like
this guy brought its own moon do you
know guys don't think but there's you
know I think my character would be it's
just I'm I'm equal parts eccentric and
kind of Awesome tations but all of that
is because I think it's funny it's like
I don't really care how I look I'd
rather dress in a way that makes me
laugh and other people laugh yeah that's
kind of fun and then Kate she sort of
fits my white kate is like you know also
thinks it's funny and she kind of likes
that I dress like this just because it's
just clearly I don't give a [ __ ] you
know money of like kind of an Ignatius
Reilly do you remember can you bring
that character up but more handsome he's
like confederacy of dunces do you
remember that yeah yeah do you ever do
you ever feel cuz you're the only person
I know that kind of rocks a mullet you
know yeah and so do you ever feel a
little within the contest of your accent
and your sort of whole vibe do you ever
feel kind of like a character or no no I
feel like I felt like that sort of true
to who you are in your background I
think in my heart it makes me feel good
having longer hair nice um and I always
had like a big nose when I was like I've
always still have it and I'll see that
well is there a lot of brothers and
sisters will come over to see what's up
when I'm wandering around so that's how
I know some of them a bird will stop
down here you know that's when you know
but so I think for me having long I
would see pictures of myself with
shorter hair and it would make me feel I
don't know longer hair I feel like I can
just hide a little bit you know I just
feel sometimes like I need a little bit
more space from the world a little bit
that's really that's interesting because
there are I think those are two types of
comedians there's sort of a comedian
that really actually in real life
doesn't want to be gregarious and
outgoing and on and all that kind of
stuff and maybe even feels a little bit
socially awkward and then it sounds like
you take some pains to sort of say okay
I need you know a little bit of space
here a little bit of that and I
I do a lot of things I don't all feel
like I have to be on all the time as you
can tell right now but I do kind of I do
exude this yeah fire alarm or just like
a truly nihilistic don't give a [ __ ]
kind of thing but I'll change my
appearance please Don based on
characters that I'm playing a lot yeah
first time I had long hair was for a
character that had just gotten out of
jail and that for me that's my fire
alarm it is new battery and I had I grew
long hair for it and I kind of grew a
beard and then I sort of some people
started to say others in fact Chelsea
Handler was like you look a lot better
with longer hair because your head is so
a blog you know and I think that's true
yeah yeah then I'll kind of stick with
it and then Kate just kind of likes this
cake is just kind of likes to she likes
a six and a half o'clock shadow mm-hmm
so I usually kind of keep that gone but
yeah I mean I don't I'm less concerned
about my parents like I'll cut wait for
a role or I rented Silicon Valley I
always gained weight for that character
for Ehrlich and but just being like so
like out like you're outs you've you
seem like outspoken even like at your
spirit kind of I like it that's any
sense does it is that is that you is it
just you or do you feel like you like no
that's me because it would seem
exhausting to be able like I you know
it's like a you know it's like when you
see a guy like have those plates on the
thing you know on the spikes on those
things yeah eat or whatever which I can
do by the way getting you really yeah a
lot of circus arts have actually in my
act right that's perfect that makes
perfect sense but I can spin plates and
I juggle cigar boxes and I'm a juggler
and and my act now is like this one man
philosophy circus it's like I have a
ventriloquist dummy with a smaller
ventriloquist dummy with a smaller
ventriloquist dummy that has a slightly
larger ventriloquist dummy and the
audience plays the slide trombone while
I do one-liners and there's juggling and
glow-in-the-dark juggling right so you
have you need that much
to be going on I do feel fun for me and
I also love that show I love the idea of
it being a real like a show so I have
I'm more PT Barnum in me than Mitch
Hedberg yeah put that and so that for me
is kind of yeah that's my speed I also
was born with an arteriovenous
malformation in your heart no it's it's
a brain condition where there's a
malformation your brain in this case
who's in my frontal lobe and because the
brain so amazing the elasticity of
allows it to sort of figure out how to
act as a normal human being but with
less brain matter and what we found cuz
I have like a team of doctors that sort
of monitor me and hang me since 2010
because I have a I had the AVM
hemorrhaged and I had to go and get it
removed so I have a golf ball sized
piece of my brain that they took out so
right in my frontal lobe there's like
you know your thoughts important that's
the tattoo and so what I think happened
was I have less frontal lobe than other
people so it has to work double time so
I take a lot of medication both to
prevent seizures and then one of the
medications is to prevent seizures as
see seizure preventative like components
to it but it's also to control mania and
I'm prone to manic episode so I'm not
bipolar I'm not like a I get depressed
and then I but I am prone to manic
episodes if I laughs and the and those
manic episodes are like your brain just
is moving so quickly and you don't know
you're in a manic episode anything oh
well this must be this and it connects
to this and it's this and so sometimes I
think that that may have contributed a
little bit in addition to how hard I
worked and my work ethic that's a bad
mix yeah yeah just not your work ethic
but when you have to work really hard
and you have some mental uncomfort going
on and it's getting heavy it's mixed as
scary isn't yeah and it can also just be
a lot of can just be a go-go-go
mentality but I wonder do I have that
level of work ethic because I'm Anna or
does working that hard sort of egg on
the mania
but I do really well especially on the
medication it's just that you know that
manic energy I think in some ways I'll
take a dose right now if you know I'm
saying there were times where I would
take a dose of that if you had it yeah -
right because you have so much going on
yeah I'd won a little manic energy see
this so this is the opposite so the
medication kind of pulls pulls that
maybe ever monitor the medicine just to
see okay maybe I'll take you know do
five Lesley so I can do it I do the only
no no cuz I can do what I can do on the
medication it's that if I start to get
manic then I'll take it more of it I
says it's almost like a and oh man I
think a long time and now I don't smoke
weed it's pretty weird
now I right now I'm not smoking weed and
I also Nick City here
and I was also hi I'm just here to tell
you I'm I'm Verizon and not only do I
have Verizon I work for them so I'm
gonna ask you guys to leave immediately
yeah thank you big fan of your you guys
but not your network yeah okay we have
the largest 5g network thank you hey
guys that's all right
hightail it that's the T and t-mobile
just get your tails out of here you're
so nice I love to when you were like
y'all from the church that there was
hurt that first guy was throwing Church
energy yeah he did have Church in it and
then he had the little backup guy who
was on recovery I like a guy did he's
wearing exactly what you would wear if
you're like so are you are you familiar
with Jesus Christ and the Latter day
Saints or you just know about Jesus yeah
we want to talk to you about all the
latter days of all the latter-day saints
you don't like him Bobby a bear pants
willing me we want to talk about all the
greats mayor drew brees yeah they used
to vote one time uh Jehovah's Witness
came over when I was in Tucson and I had
like
no friends mangrove religious mmm I grew
up going to church sometimes Oh God so
but there was a lot of like just
religion in the area you know a lot of
people because we got is that area yeah
and we have smaller environments people
don't have as many places to go get
together so it's like a lot of times
church is a place also where you just
get to see oh yeah it's community more
than its about the god of yes yeah
you'll go and you take your kids because
they get to play with other kids from
but yeah this man when I was in Tucson I
was really struggling in college and
this man you didn't have a lot of
friends yeah I was just like real
depressed and I just didn't have a lot
of friends in this uh Jehovah's Witness
would come over and then I had video
games oh and then he was definitely
slacking for the Lord because he would
come over for the Lord with his
autobiography slacking for the Lord oh
he would come over and just like that's
so good so it was almost like you're
like I get a friend out of God and he's
like and I could flip video game yes
that's a good it's a symbiotic
relationship so that's interesting to me
that you you know you seem a little bit
and tell me if this is not the case no
it's okay how are do that to you wants
ya know but I think this is actually an
interesting thing that we like know each
other but don't know that much about
each other yeah so I just would never
have taken you as a guy that had any
kind of depression any sort of feelings
of like I could use a little bit more
manic energy any kind of with longer
hair glasses or a scarf I give myself a
little space from there to me you felt
like kind of a crazy goodtime guy who
was you know down to party whenever but
that wasn't that wasn't your identity it
just like you were sort of comfortable
in any situation whatever and that's
sort of how I see you when you're on
stage is you have this energy of that
with the audience yeah so that's really
interesting because I would say that I'm
as quick to get I feel as comfortable
with people on stage as I do off stage I
feel pretty comfortable being out and
about Kate a lot of times is like TJ you
have to stop burping in public
right like he is burp like 10 20 times
you're just passing by people and I'm
very loud so a lot of times I've heard
that
yeah I'm not joking I was talking one of
my friends I'll know it over here he's
like oh I see that guy in our
neighborhood sometimes he's always
really loud on this is that real and he
was starting an ice cream parlor so my
buddy said where was it in New York in
New York yeah really and I said I don't
know I said I just you know I said I
don't know the ice cream broke because I
want to go and support if he opens it up
I know he said you were starting one it
sounded like but he also could have been
eavesdropping so I never intended on
staring at ice cream parlor but I
definitely would have said yeah I see
then the problem is I don't I'm I'm not
as aware of my surroundings I'm just
aware of like what is the mission
statement what are we trying to do or
how are we having fun so it's not really
a so yeah so it's not like thing you're
putting on it's just that's who you are
no and I really it's even something
that's even more like in your system if
you have I mean that's wild bro if they
just on Loeb I can't even imagine that
it's pretty crazy and I never even
noticed anything about it or thought
anything of it until it becomes sort of
like a medical emergency because that I
did a bit about it on this is not
happening
but that surgery they came in and they
go so this is a pretty serious like
surgery and I was like yeah I assume
you're opening up my [ __ ] head yeah
and they sort of were like so about it's
a 10% fatality right so about one in ten
people who get this surgery done died
and I was like okay what happens if I
don't get the surgery because it was
elective he said you don't have to get
it so this is when I had ten people die
or you don't you don't have to get it I
said well what happens if you don't get
it and he was like mmm you probably die
in your mid-30s and I was like let's
roll the dice and get the surgery done
right one on a ten ain't bad my opinion
here on it and some Dungeons and Dragons
[ __ ] right there that's the ten sided
die
and so um you know I didn't take away
near a hit point you think after you got
it like is there times where you can
feel an idea kind of going in and
there's just so so that's a great point
so what I said was I said you know I
said so the the the main thing I want to
ask you is why I still be funny after
the operation and the guy was like what
and I said like if I get the operation
will I still be funny because that's my
work I'm a comedian he goes I mean does
it he almost like does it matter don't
you want to like live and not have a
brain hemorrhage and he said I mean I
assume so I don't you know you're not
using that part of your brain now it was
malformed in the womb so we remove it
we're not removing any of your like
cognitive efficiencies you're not
cognitively deficient right now so we
wouldn't see why taking out a part of
your brain that you don't use would
because they think so
I said because if it's not gonna make me
funny I kind of almost rather do the
maybe die in your mid-30s thing and that
floored the whole room all of the
doctors were like that doesn't seem like
something we'd ever really hurt that
doesn't check out yeah yeah cuz you know
when you said that though did you really
but I also have a very interesting
relationship with death both like
philosophically and following some
philosophers specifically Epicurus which
he has this great quote which is like
because people would have always come to
him who were afraid of death which was
mostly actually in Greece noble men and
people of great wealth because they kind
of knew that all the church like stuff
was [ __ ] but yeah that's a totally I
mean that's you know it's like Zeus and
all that Arab stuff but they would be
scared about it and so they would say
you know I'm afraid of death and he
would say why I had stuff to yeah I
don't want to die if you have right
exactly if you don't have anything
you're like let's check out a little
more yeah let's see what's going on here
yeah let's see what except it
that's hilarious maybe I'll get a car in
heaven
taking the [ __ ] bus here on earth and
so he says that when you are death is
not and when death is you are not so you
really never cross paths with death so
why would you even worry about it or
fear it because you'll never encounter
it and so I was sending that stuff like
on my own in high school and then kind
of became an absurdist and sort of
Annihilus as I entered college
definitely and yeah feel it you feel
that yeah oh yeah if other people are
picking for the basketball team in PE
and you're like you know you and death
never really meet each other you just
kind of cross paths yeah I think I did
so I did the emoji movie in part because
I like to entertain children I want
those movies to be funny so that the
parents don't want to like beat
themselves over the head with a
sledgehammer because they have to watch
those movies all the time if you'd like
some movie they're watching over and
over oh yeah but I also do excuse me I
did that movie yogi berra 3d and I did
transformers and I did the emotion would
be because I want a funny credit for my
stand-up so now when I get introduced
now you don't reduce me it's like TJ
Miller from Deadpool or Silicon Valley
it's you know young kids sometimes
they'll come up to me and they'll be
like so so how do you want me to
introduce you you can tell they kind of
are like I want to get this right so let
me just you know get really clear
because they're expecting me to say like
well just put do this and this and this
or whatever that whatever people do
there and and I'll be like um just the
star of the emoji movie you're like but
what do you what do you want me to
introduce is that women do CEA's and I'm
like yeah and then kind of [ __ ] with him
I'll go but I mean really hit star like
the star of the emoji movie okay and
it's good to emphasise emoji also cuz
that's what the movie is about and you
he's gonna hit even hit movie also
because it is a movie so just but really
it starts with the star of the emoji
movie
mic is he serious is he kidding whatever
but I always found Ali's follow that up
with like I honestly don't give a [ __ ]
clearly because I'm telling you the
emoji movie and so that's kind of how I
approach life is like I'll do entire
films
sort of for the service of the joke of a
stand-up credit being that thing so
that's kind of my approach to life Janos
I really don't take it seriously and
people say don't take life seriously
it's like no I really do not take any of
it seriously it's truly I'm an absurdist
and it's really really fun but so within
the context of what you asked about the
the doctors and is that true that you I
really was sort of saying if I can be
Who I am and continue to make people
laugh because that's what's important to
me not to be it's not to have people
like me or laugh at like laugh at the
things that I say but to make people
happy if I only have forget how old I
was then but it was like if I only have
a decade or so left to keep doing what
I'm doing now and I'm feel so blessed to
be doing and I would only say bless on
your podcast cuz it feels appropriate I
appreciate that
I'll bring the guys right back in yeah
Verizon is the only network a stream
straight to the Lord I'm sorry too we
start pitching to them we're like you
get unlimited data and unlimited wishes
about what your heaven will be like we
should have man God so I sort of
seriously am I was like I'm so blessed
what you haven't data and wishes also
you don't get wishes in heaven that's a
genie I don't know where the [ __ ] that
came from dude it could be your heaven
though it could happen if ya the wishes
you could get to the wish in heaven the
unlimited data and wish in heaven so I
but I yeah I think I was very very to
deadly serious in fact that I would
rather continue to make people happy and
do what I feel so lucky to be doing then
kind of no longer be funny and just live
longer
yes I've never understood why that is
the goal to just live as long
you can't it's not some race it's not
the competition or anything like that so
you should really want to live you know
20 yeah 20 years more with purpose with
sort of reward with feeling in and of
yourself with kind of self-efficacy and
those things rather than just go like 50
years to then retire and go on cruise
ships now if that's living purposefully
I talk about this in my act a little bit
it's living purposefully is undertaking
change from person to person if you know
I look at somebody who works at State
Farm and I don't think like oh geez nine
to five two weeks of vacation and then
you retire and go on Carnival Cruises
and it's like know if that person is
smart what they'll do is say I work in
an industry where I help people feel
safer where when the inevitable happens
it doesn't [ __ ] them financially I
have a consistent job so I can
consistently provide for my family and
see my work adding purpose to their life
yeah and and maybe able to be present
for my relationship and then all I want
to do is go on Carnival Cruise Lines and
see the world there's nothing better
it's unlimited seafood yeah anything
it's many scallops and pineapple and I
usually do a scallop pineapple sort of
mix yeah take two rings of pineapple put
the scallops in between and that's with
scallop conical sandwich but I think so
I don't I think everybody can sort of
live with purpose and live well and
people sometimes look at me and they go
oh wow you know I mean you just could
you couldn't have a better situation
then then TJ and it's it's like you know
Kate and I have really like I cane I
have so much fun that I went before the
podcast to part of a movie with her Wow
so she wanted to see this movie and I
just wanted to go so we could like see
20 minutes of it together I was like I'm
gonna take off so I'm not late to the
podcast cos we got to leave later too
because she's going to Dallas with me
but that's very rare she doesn't go so I
only see Kate 3 days a week so because
like you I'm on the road every weekend
do you are you're torn a lot yeah yeah I
see you Criss crossing oh yeah same
quick question to get back I'll just
want it so do you find though that
sometime
like it does it ever affect like your
because you the way you are is very
unique you agree with that and now that
you are is very well thank you
appreciate that man and um that's true
it's not it's not like a compliment
because you gave me a compliment yeah
it's just like I think the best
stand-ups really I mean we all talk
about having our own unique voice but
the best stand-ups have sort of slowly
not even whittled down but molded and
shaped what it is that makes them wholly
unique into a funny version of that yeah
he can share with an audience on stage
one never one and I remember when I was
always like I don't want I don't care if
they remember a joke I just want them to
remember me that's what that's so smart
I mean that I just wanted to be you
remembered and he was like or not even
remember I just wanted to be yeah what
do you say going well I think this is
interesting and tell me if you agree
that people don't go to see the material
they go to see you yeah and so you can
have the best material in the world you
can Mitch Hedberg has some of the
greatest one-liners Steven right but
they're the way that they were that's
what you're really remembering you can
quote jokes but you wouldn't be able to
quote jokes if that was just a not
memorable person and then some people
figure that out and maybe they're not
super hilarious but they decide I'm
gonna stop being me and be Larry the
Cable Guy right and now I own a jet and
live on a thousand acres jet we can
grill on top of - yeah oh my god
definitely and so it is I think it's
that it's not your material it's you and
a big part of I think why I'm successful
in film and television is I sort of seem
like and I really have this energy in
real life like you and I would be
friends that's to everybody watching
they're like oh he's really funny but
they're like that I'd get along with
that guy you know and that has more to
do with me and and I do this all the
time I don't look I wouldn't say I
talked to strangers all the time but I'm
always joking with people not to get
laughs but because I want to add to
their day so like yeah and I'm sure you
do the same because yes sometimes yeah
I'll definitely check in with people as
much as I can when I'm just wandering
around in person yeah
to get a yet tell somebody nuts
something nice make somebody smile that
kind of stuff yeah I love giving I love
giving compliments especially to girls
yeah and I do it a lot when I'm with
Kate so that they immediately know like
oh he's not being creepy right cuz I
don't do in a creepy way but sometimes
if you're like yes I sent a raven over
to [ __ ] drop a note into a ladies
yeah it's almost always a crow and so
you know I think that one of the things
that I do like doing is kind of joking
with people or I love to ask people
questions that they aren't usually asked
so I I sort of very interested in people
in the component of you know I say to if
I go and see a movie I'll say what have
you seen that you like and it's this and
then I'll ask them how is Impractical
Jokers doing and then they'll he'll say
you know what it's not doing as well to
be honest with you and I was like do you
think that's because this is the
ArcLight
or do you think that that might be
happening across the board he's like I
don't know I mean I guess the ArcLight
maybe wouldn't be the demographic but
you know what we get this this and this
and those all did really well like do
you think it's because you see it for
free like it's on TV and it's on TV a
lot and he and he was like yeah that's a
really good point it's kind of free and
then now you're asked and then just pay
for it I say do you think that they kind
of basically taught people we do this
for you for free you can just turn us on
whenever and now they're saying like you
got to leave your house get in your car
go to it and you're gonna want popcorn
awesome and he goes yeah I do I think
that's the case and then he goes from
being who is he he's that take the guy
taking the token selling tickets right
then he goes from a ticket taker and the
guy working behind the computer to now
somebody who's thinking about the world
of their work and also just gave me an
analysis that only he can really give
and I see him be like yeah I think
that's exactly right and I'm like I
think you're right and then there's this
great moment where he's just like badass
dude I I do yeah I connected the dots
for this guy who's dressed like a
[ __ ] lunatic yeah and I think is from
the I think he's the star of the emoji
me and Andy the star that's right you're
right I got to start telling him to hit
the edges yeah each of them a different
level
I'm gonna draw a chart it's like we want
these sort of really high stars got to
be a little bit higher emoji here
because we want them to know what movies
about but movie doesn't it can kind of
be here because they know it's a movie
it's good to remind them so the star and
then actually of can be down here let's
put up here yeah let's go bear star me
actually do this is a half the the emoji
movie yeah let's get there I'll play I
play an audio recording worm that I did
and I'm just like let me text this to my
work phone so you have it this is bad
news this podcast is gonna ruin many and
openers life throughout the next decade
do you think that do you think is so
with your energy the way that you are
it's a unique way do you think that it
doesn't fit sometimes like in the
template of things yeah by tryna just
cuz the last thing I want is for people
being comfortable because again I'm not
really focused on me as much if anything
I'm focused too much on other people I
hate to let people down Kate said last
night I had to cancel a show and I hate
canceling shows and she said you have to
be able to cancel the show you're double
booked you're you're not gonna be able
to do it I need you in this situation
and so then I canceled and the the
Booker Jay Davis who's awesome and as
always one of those guys that believes
in me text me every month or so to be
like hey I know you're in New York but
let me know when you're in Los Angeles
nice guy she's a really good dude and
cares a lot about comedy so I felt bad
cancel but he was totally cool he was
like no problem let me know when you get
back so Kate has to sometimes remind me
like it's okay to let people down when
you need to sort of put yourself first
so she'll actually say if she something
will great yourself first a little bit
more TJ no I appreciate that you're
doing what you're doing but you got to
think about putting yourself first
because otherwise your family's pulling
you in one direction your friends are
pulling in one direction the book Kurds
are pulling in another direction your
agents are pulling in another direction
so nose gotta be about me and you
sometimes have just got to be about you
yeah hey there this is a good episode
I'm enjoying it I have to let you know
though that inside of my pants
there's something unique and I'm talking
about Mac Weldon and that's not a man it
is a man's name but probably the closest
a man will ever get to my jump it is a
premium men's essential brand that
believes in smart design and premium
fabrics Mac Weldon does indeed offer
industry-leading underwear they are the
Tony Stewart of underwear these things
and they're so just they grip you they
hold you were you going to work what do
you got to do you got a babysit what do
you got to do huh
you got to dig in the sand and look for
something somebody lost something you
could do it you got to borrow a shovel
or something from a neighbor put these
on before you go over there be a man
they are the one-stop-shop for men's
basics of all kinds Mac Weldon will be
the most comfortable underwear socks
shirts undershirts hoodies and
sweatpants and more that you will ever
wear now I haven't experienced the other
there are Kouta mental pieces but they
have a lot of silver underwear that are
naturally antimicrobial that means they
eliminate odor so if you stink
voila now you don't Mack Weldon really
does value its loyal customers that's
why they've created the Weldon Blue
loyalty program simply create an account
it's totally free place an order and
never pay shipping again once you
purchase 200 hours worth of products
from Mac Weldon not only will you
continue to receive free shipping but
you will also start saving 20% on every
order you make for the next year hmm
this also grants you access to new
products before they are released to
anyone else I love my Mac Weldon I have
them on right now my junk feels secure I
feel like I could do I could do HVAC
work I have to let you know for 20% of
your first order visit Mac Weldon M ack
wel do n.com
and enter promo code theo if you are a
man and you have genitals and but take
care of them and these will be the
greatest supplement you add to your
crotch and rear
I'm not joking Mac Weldon calm enter
promo code Theo and now back to the
episode hate to interrupt you but I need
to because I'm not sure if you got any
skills or not you know a lot of times I
wonder who's listening what are they
doing do they can never do a recipe can
they build a fire you know what I'm
saying could they make a kool-aid could
they draw an art and I don't know that's
why Skillshare is bringing you this
episode Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
25,000 classes and design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fuel your career your creativity and
your curiosity there are classes in
social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing and even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion or start a little
side hustle do this you know what I'm
saying make a little something over
there do that sell that get that or gain
professional skills Skillshare is there
to keep you learning thriving and
reaching new goals are you a freelancer
try bookkeeping for freelancers how to
handle your finances one of their most
popular courses join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today our listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare comm slash Theo
von to start your two months now that's
Skillshare dot-com slash Theo von and do
you I feel like so right now are you
going through like a rebuilding phase in
your work I feel like cuz you're getting
back out on the road yeah I mean now I
am wholly focused on stand-up because I
started to see like gyfer I was like oh
wow do you I mean I'm too in like 50
weeks out of the year and I take time
off when it makes sense to be with Kate
or really good news that I got yesterday
the film that I did with Drew Barrymore
getting to Tribeca Film Festival that
to New York City I know I only have to
walk 15 minutes to get there and that's
great because I'm gonna take those two
weeks sort of the weekends on either
like move those and then take those two
weeks and it's they're the perfect clubs
because helium in Philadelphia and then
Omaha which do you work though I'm a
funny one when Colleen Quinn she's so
sweet and she officiated our wedding
acutely she married Kate and me and
here's the redhead yeah and here's the
strangest part hot yeah it should
beautiful Kate and Kate chose that I
didn't say hey I love this comedy club
owner Kate had visited a couple times I
think she's like she just has this
energy I really wanted so I was lucky
it's that Club and then another club
that I'm very close to those people that
are sort of booking and own those clubs
and so I'm gonna move that chunk and
then just be in New York for the Tribeca
Film Festival and I'll do sets in New
York I all the time will do three four
five it's a big part of why I moved
there right and but outside it out I'm
trying every weekend because I realized
that I was doing so much film and
television stuff that um but just with
regards to stand-up that maximum during
Silicon Valley I could really do a sort
of a bus tour and then maybe some clubs
but that's just a month that's just
thirty shows it's just 35 shows out of
the year you know odd you do 35 shows in
six weeks when you're when you're on the
road and so now I'm really trying to put
in the time and grind and hustle enough
to not just be a really good comedian
but hopefully be a great comedian and
you know how much work that takes you
know it takes a lot of work and there's
the road as a whole different skill set
like I'm so in awe of you guys in the
way I did Adam Ray's podcast so just a
tiger belly I'm really in awe of the way
that you guys have the business acumen
to have built these podcasts because I
what I love about them is it helps your
touring but it really does connect with
your audience and you're providing
something with them that sort of stand
up ask but also has a lot to do with
pulling back the curtain saying this is
Theo von and this is the Oh
with different people yeah and this is
what the Oh Vaughn is interested in
about the other people and this is what
comes I think that's really amazing it's
a place I feel like I don't have to be
scared a lot of times sometimes it's
still kind of scary you know like yeah
III definitely hurts and it surely
started out that way doing podcasting
was like a place I felt like that didn't
have to be I don't know just it's just
it's such a life's hard to learn by
yourself you know and a lot of people
these days or about a lot of us are a
lot of people kind of by themselves or
feel that way I think yes especially
with social media which was supposed to
connect us I know that's just you online
looking it's people that couldn't be
further away from you and completely
anonymous it's very very strange yes I
think podcasting does a little bit of
Brit it's a little bit more yeah like
it's long-form it's like you get to you
kind of get to enjoy someone for who
they for what they are and what they
aren't you know it's like you just get
to it's almost it's kind of like a
lesson a little bit in acceptance even
when I watch other guys podcasts and
stuff it's like man I might not agree
with everything or that they say or some
of their ideas and stuff but you know I
care I do care about that person so it's
like you get you know it's that I don't
agree with you say but I'll fight to the
death for your right to say it
yeah so you really are kind of yeah
tumblr yeah I watch it somewhere I steal
all that stuff and I use it in
conversation it's mostly how is much
cooler not a new site yeah right yeah I
like to blur and the tweeter yeah we had
a video question that came in
let's see it let's hit it no we put it
out on social media these are all they
knew you're coming in nothing's great I
love Lisa did you a Canadian she does
kind of a Canadian happy joyous outdoors
is wood in the background yeah she's got
a scarf like you one little space I go
from the trees from the space in the
space age I see oh my gosh GJ did she
hear me turn it up no she's kidding I'm
kidding
people ask that
oh yeah Eddie Bravo talk like a video
question Bravo talkback someone for 11
minutes straight video yeah hi TJ hi
Theo my questions for TJ I was wondering
what was the first I wish that you fell
in love with was the first wedge on wall
not Canadian she said sandwich oh I like
do you think she said armoire I did ah
the first armoire I fell in love with
was my parents my parents not bedroom
buddies and the second floor of a bright
it's turn in the center I thought I said
it on water is that a chest of drawers
what is that and my mother said no
that's an armoire and I said it was love
at first chest no I first sandwich I
ever fell in love with I think yeah you
know there's this sushi restaurant in
Greenwich Village we have a couple
places that we go and we eat and we feel
safe actually I relate to you a little
bit in what you're saying in New York
and in general but it's a little bit
more to do with feeling scared that
people are I mean it doesn't freak me
out so much but the fact that that guy's
like he was really loud and is he's
starting an ice cream parlor that
reminds me of something that I don't
think about very often which is I'm
famous people kind of know who I am
right and so we really pick and choose
we didn't curate where we go so we don't
go to many places in New York there's a
jazz club that we feel very safe there's
another great jazz club but we don't go
there because that doesn't feel safe to
us it's younger people drinking people
are drinking a lot more it's not as much
about the Jazz so we can't go places
where will you become the focus and then
there's certain restaurants as a
restaurant called for Charles prime rib
you can't really get a reservation there
either you're not allowed to take
pictures or talk to other customers
really unless they're engaged and you're
connected by the maitre d there's only
12 tables there's a sushi restaurant
that we go to that only has 14 seats
it's a sushi bar and it's just two
employees and then this is called
omakase room by Tatsu and Tatsu is the
chef and he's you guys pick and choose
where you guys spend time really do but
the last course it's omakase so it's an
18 course meal each course is just a
piece of sushi and the last piece is his
it's the eel oh yeah which is it but
also grills it does it anyway and the
first time I had it immediately I am I
went back to my childhood when my mother
used to make a tuna fish sandwich on
white bread with the crust and it tasted
exactly the same and that was the first
I would always ask my mother can I have
a tuna fish sandwich because she had the
perfect tuna de Mayo yeah to me a ratio
right that's it the perfect ratio
you can't have an obviously I was
struggling and then he goes tuna to me
oh yeah yeah it's she had that exact
thing down and sometimes she put relish
in it but really she loved it she had
the ratio just perfect now is the first
one I fell in love with and now as an
adult I'm really obsessed with the
perfect hamburger and that's all about
ratio also it's all about which elements
you're putting and how much of it yeah
so there's a couple places that have the
best burgers I've ever had in Los
Angeles burger lounge is really up there
and then over on Sunset no no there's
one in Larchmont Village Way in Pasadena
there's a burger line there it's so good
it's all grass-fed beef and then in look
the girth at Cal can do whatever he
wants on his own time do but I'm saying
is is the burger good man that's what
I'm sure that's true too but the
grass-fed for some reason tastes better
to me and then there's a place in New
York called B rgr which has sort of the
perfect kind of it's it's just perfect
and there's a place called burger joint
which is in a hotel and that's a that
sort of perfect ratio but a very
different burger and then there's a
famous hamburger in another place where
we feel safe called Minetta tavern have
you ever played the Comedy Cellar
yeah so it's right on that strip on
MacDougal and Minetta tavern has
something called the Black Label burger
and that's thirty-six dollars to buy
that burger and it is well worth it you
get you know you can only get a couple a
year or something but it's the highest
quality meat lease it's the perfect and
you don't really put ketchup mustard or
mayo on that it's just kind of the
burger and they do Carmellini of burgers
huh yeah kind of yeah right and then you
I do cheese with it cuz I think that's
enough you know I could see you doing
that yeah throw a little cheese on there
look I got to tell you straight up and
straight honest that being healthy is
the goal being fit is the goal but being
sore and in pain from workouts not good
you could spend a ton of money to hire a
personal masseuse or you could do what I
did and check out power dot power dot
puts a modern spin on clinically proven
muscle stimulation a lot of times you
need to go to like a fancy healthcare
place to get stem for your muscles but
now with power dot you can simply apply
the different pads to the placement
where your muscles are sore and you can
stem them yourself that's right it also
comes with an app that guides you
through the process with pre-designed
programs like massage and pad placement
photos for places like your lower back
don't let them all on your cheeks and
just electrocuting your smile you want
to take care of yourself the app is also
packed with tons of education a newsfeed
allows you to learn how the top athletes
and physicians in the world are using
power dot I have mine on right now
getting the top of my chest muscles got
to take care of those by removing the
control unit and connecting via
bluetooth to your mobile phone the
actual unit itself fits easily into the
palm of your hand the app has preset
programs like speed up recovery improve
athletic performance reduce pain and
Rehab from injury and today power dot is
offering us customers a free 30 day
trial plus an additional 20 percent off
for our listeners go to power dot-com
slash Theo
that's powa our do t dot c om /t h EO
and use the code theo at checkout for
20% off of your order that's 20% off
that's power dot-com slash Theo and use
code Theo for 20% off take care of your
muscles take care of your own self use
power dot so you have was a there's some
was you know that I was with whenever
you had the the we got a question right
here what's up Theo what's up TJ say I'm
from Arkansas had a quick question for
you TJ do you have it in every one of
your contracts that no matter what you
can do whatever the [ __ ] you want with
your facial hair kind of looks like you
just wing it every time and I think it's
awesome Gang Gang Gang Marquez's he's
got he's obviously on break he's got the
safety vest on safety first baby you
know I think that's that's a good point
and also from a gentleman with great
facial hair look at how he's right in
the middle
he's got nothing going on he's doing
what I'm doing which is taking off the
soul patch but he's got a good sort of
length of beard good on you man it's
everybody might contract but I think
it's understood just like that I'm gonna
improvise so you can't expect me to just
do the lines as written even sometimes
I'll say I don't think this is the right
lines
yeah I'll notice that even when I walk
on there I'm like he had there has to be
yeah and I'll supervise I'm not gonna
come and say I don't like that line what
else do you got because I'm a writer
I'll come and I'll say okay I don't
think that's really the funniest line or
doesn't quite fit here so here's about
five other options that I came up with
and let's talk like what do you think
would be good um so just like people
expect that they kind of know that I'm
going to do with my appearance what I
want the drew Barrymore film which is
called the stand and in the stand in I
did I
I cut weight and had the same facial
hair and haircut as my former manager
mm-hmm
Barry Katz that's the note that's the
that's the character that I'm sort of
playing is that as that manager I split
amicably with hmm and and so they just
knew I talked to the director about it
but they just know I'm gonna have a very
specific idea the weirdest thing that
ever happened to me with regards to can
I do whatever the [ __ ] I want as I did
this movie called ready player one I
should say this picture called ready
player one and I was really nervous the
night before I just was
I'm not really an actor I'm a comedian
should I be reading an acting book or
something I'm about to go in and Steven
Spielberg is gonna direct me and is that
shahi should I be more prepared and I
was just pacing outside of the weirdest
state that they put us up and around
this fountain just pacing pacing pacing
and finally I was kind of like you know
what you've never worried about this
with any other film like just change
your voice that's what you do for
everything that's what you did for
Wiesel and Deadpool that's what you know
he surtax like this and then Erlich from
Silicon Valley sort of talks more like
this and I was like okay let's figure
out what that what is the and I thought
about it's like he's a bounty hunter in
this video game world he's obviously a
nerd because he plays video games
non-stop all the time it's how he makes
his money everything I said well who
would be his idol Boba Fett right I mean
obviously that's who we all love from
Star Wars and this guy's actually a
bounty hunter so I just studied Boba
Fett's he only has like five lines oh
wow cops that cop some of that vibe yeah
cop that vibe and then went in and I was
like all right I'm just gonna ask
Stephen Spielberg you know does he think
this is a good idea if it's not then I'm
just gonna say to him what you know I'm
open to anything else and just let him
kind of direct you know is he handsome
guy handsome guy the Avadh first person
for that to be she looks like but also
yeah let's pull him up but I think yeah
he's a handsome guy he's definitely got
an iconic look he kind of he's got a
little bit of a look like you look there
he is yeah yeah some guy but like he's
got a look yeah I could see me look like
David Spade's dead a little like - its
dad we're getting some serious nodding
in the booth with that observation right
on it does not not very buddy he's the
nicest guy you think how intimidating so
I go up to him oh yeah be intimidated
and I say so I was thinking you know his
idol this I rock this I rock Saito would
be Boba Fett you know because that's
this so I thought I would change my
voice and kind of talk like Boba Fett
what do you think about that and he goes
yeah I think that's great let's yeah
let's do that whatever you think and it
was so insane to have this guy kind of
go well it's obviously whatever you want
it to be yeah because to him he hired
you I heard Woody Allen is like this he
hired you and hiring you was the last he
wants to do with you you're supposed to
figure out what you're gonna do and he
trusts that you're that's the reason he
hired you was and even in that one I
said thank you Steven Spielberg for
having me in your movie he said oh yeah
no there's no one else we wrote the part
for you and I thought oh my god that's
crazy but it's that he thought about the
movie he's a fan of mine it's been
helping me throughout my career and was
like TJ you'll do great with this so
whatever he wants to do he'll do with it
and it worked out really well and he'll
give you you know he'll give you notes
and stuff obviously but it's really
notes on how to improve your performance
but as far as the facial hair and that
one I did they did give a [ __ ] because I
had to shave because I was in the game
and so I had to have a hundred and fifty
black dots all over my face and wear one
of those skin tight suits with the ping
pong balls all over it and a helmet with
two little cameras and lights that so I
was all motion-capture Wow most parts it
was really that was a crazy experience
but I guess the real answer that
question is yes I or no I do not in my
contract say I can do whatever the [ __ ]
I want with my face sharks sometimes
Steven Spielberg wants you be a clean
baby boys but yeah on your face you got
a show-up diaper ready driver ready do
you find that like having so having like
a kind of a you know I don't know if
it's like whimsical do you feel like
whimsical a lot of times like you know
we're getting back to like some of the
main ian Sep you're talking about like
do you ever do you feel like that you're
in control of yourself a lot of times or
does it feel like almost uncontrollable
it's very rare that I would feel like
okay I'm out of control here with my
thinking but it has happened I missed a
day on Silicon Valley because I had a
manic episode that night and when I see
a manic episode I mean I thought that
there were birds flying by there were
actually drones and then which were
probably bats
and I thought I thought I really
remember so vividly I was loading an
Internet page and it said visit China
you come see China China China China and
then it changed they thought for sure
they were watching me through the I
could have been real the camera I know
for reals well that's well I want to
shake out recently it's okay that's why
in the main I I don't think I'll ever go
that's why in the main in the in the
mania in the midst of a manic episode
you of course you're like that could be
real but in mania you're like that's
definitely real and so I smashed the
computer and because I was afraid they
were watching me through that and you
get and all of this makes complete sense
to you but I would say that's happened
five or ten times in my entire life it's
much more and we say sense of whimsy
whimsy first thing I think of is Kate
because Kate is really she talked about
that a lot she likes I love a sense of
whimsy she likes things that are
whimsical I think it's kind of I'm
pretty carefree and it's really a
positive nihilism it's like if not nice
none of this means anything then and
then anything can mean everything that's
sort of the positive nihilist viewpoint
nothing means anything then you decide
what because anything can mean
everything so for me it's making me
laugh and doing that and that's why
Annihilus true nilus would never have a
conversation with a religious person and
be like there's no God there's you know
what are you talking about none of this
means anything you wouldn't do that
that's somebody who's like dogmatic and
not truly a nihilist right that's
somebody's more trying to push their
agenda maybe yeah because if truly
nothing means anything then who cares
yeah there's a god but whatever even
saying there's not a god doesn't mean
anything all that language is totally
meaningless bright so and if someone
believes it why take them the task if it
see if it makes them feel comfortable or
them feel good yeah and that's that is I
think a beautiful thing and positive
nihilism is this idea of you make your
own meaning that's that's we all in
effect have become that concept of God
where you can completely make your life
meaning
in any way shape or form again the State
Farm agent where it's like you can make
meaning in that or you can take other
people's meaning and feel bad in which
you had a better car and I always want
the next biggest television well that's
up but then again is it positive
nihilist I'm going but if wanting a
bigger car is gonna make you happy and
having the net the next television of
the next best television and that's
really important to you and you work
hard because of that then great that's
the meaning that you've made right and
so you get it gets to a place like you
we're talking about acceptance you get
to a place of really being accepting of
other people and what they want to need
and do the only thing I don't not very
accepting of his hecklers do you get a
lot of hecklers only in Oxon Hill
Maryland last weekend that was really
the only place he's like steer clear
oxen Ville I got uh what happened to me
oh well I got whenever like my career
started to get busier about a like a
year ago I started to have like a lot of
control issues I didn't realize that I
had like I don't realize I'm controlling
I kind of was like I just in terms of
what I just gotten used to being in a
club and knowing what the space was like
in the environment and then I felt so
responsible for everybody's hat like
Joey at the show in a theater and you
can't see them or anything like I don't
know if a lot of people realize in a
theater you're just looking at lights a
lot of times or even almost on any stage
you're just looking at lights if you
can't it's almost like two people trying
to park boats and you can't direct them
they're not listening and the you know
and you'd like to park the boats and
shut it off you know so I can it's
almost like an experiment so just
performing into a light sometimes you're
like performing a little bit into a void
and you know in a comedy club you can at
least see the front row yeah and they
have somebody yells something you can
either maybe see them or you can kind of
talk to them in a way where it's like
we're in the same room right I mean in
the theater they're like we're in the
audience you're on the stage
so we're our entity is audience there's
a huge barrier between us and the stage
and I talk in my stand-up a lot about
ripping your attention away from these
screens that are ruining our lives and
how happy I am that they came to a
setting like this which is live and is
I'll never perform for this exact
audience again no other audience will
see this exact perform
this is a singular sort of time in our
lives that we're sharing together that
doesn't work as well even that material
doesn't work as well in a big theatre if
I'm performing for a thousand people
they're kind of like I could sort of be
watching this at home on my television
right now and when I try and improvise
which I do every show in a theatre
you're just further away and yeah feels
detached you and people cannot really
hear what people said you have to repeat
it I [ __ ] up the timing so hecklers in
that in those senses yeah I hate that
yeah I hate that because he's invasive
do you play mostly theaters now or
mostly comedy clubs or mixed juice
immensely a mix yeah I mean I've done a
lot of theaters this past year but
looking forward to doing getting backed
into some clubs and doing just working
on trying and working on some new
material
Manning that's that's that's a big part
of what I love about the clubs but I
would always rather do five shows at a
500-seat theatre than one show at a 2500
C theater and that might change as I
grow older also the material matures or
what you know how I want to present
things changes but right now kind of
back to what you're talking about with
the shift and trying to become a great
comedian that also just requires reps
it's like I need five shows much more
than one show yeah you know and that's
why when I finished a weekend of doing
five shows or six shows we had shows
I'll come back to New York and I will at
least one or two nights go and do sets
just go and do spots all around town so
I'm I'm performing a lot you know and
that's why I moved to New York I moved
because Cait is this famous installation
artist like internationally but she's
her world is in New York and so I wanted
to be with her so I moved for love oh
yeah and then also just to be able to do
so many more spots and I love the feel
like we were talking about in the very
beginning I love the feel of the I love
the energy the fire alarm energy of
doing as being a stand-up comic in New
York yeah yeah I think it it has like
yeah New York definitely has more of a
you feel like you're just part of
there's always something going on it
feels it feels fun the world feels alive
there yeah and here the world feels a
little bit more like package and like
you're waiting for like Amazon to bring
it by yeah a little sleepy a little
you're in traffic and you're stopping
and then you're starting and you're
stopping in New York is just like go go
go would you ever have you lived in New
York would you ever live there I just
live there about three minutes three
months actually I rented a room from a I
mean a fellas homosexual gentleman
actually and he said let's make that
clear so it was really well decorated
and yeah I took his bed over for you
know three months man so I've done some
things you know some lovers and I
actually still feel like I owe him $150
maybe to get them I don't know how to
clean or whenever not but anyway um but
what I'm telling you is yeah see there
for three months and I really enjoyed it
or I should fear let me stay at his
place for a little while he's great I
rent him a lot and Kate loves him she
his energy she he is such a sweet dude
and he's very present yeah and almost
every time I have a conversation with
him I walk away from it with sort of a
little bit more perspective on things
we've presently not welcome the Staples
Center in Los Angeles yeah falling out
with Kobe Bryant that make perfect sense
right first I was like what did he do at
the Staples Center and I was like oh I
see yes yes no he's a su we got he also
had that falling-out with Kobe Bryant or
you know with that whole deal and so he
but that coming from a positive
nihilistic viewpoint and I talked to him
we saw him after that Kate and I were
just walking home and he was headed
downtown I think to do the seller or
yeah do the fat black and we searched
stopped him and we talked a little bit
and then I said you know with the mark
Normand stuff mark Normand sort of spoke
about how the people calling in death
threats like why are we not focusing our
anger on those oh that's really and Ari
said yeah I heard that he said something
kind of interesting about that he said
well you know what it's like it's like
you know you just because because you've
had the media go out for you and I was
like
yeah and I do want to say because I
wanted to say this to him I said and my
thing is I didn't think it was a funny
joke I didn't think it was funny but you
didn't he's like then that's fine that's
fine that's not the point of it
I was like but I don't think it's wrong
if that was your thing and that's what
you do then I don't think you did
anything wrong I think you got the
reaction that you were gonna get by
doing that yeah that's how you learn
whatever it is you don't and you don't
expect that people are not gonna react
if you're being a provocateur then you
expect people to feel provoked and to
react in that way which is a form of art
to a lot of people yes and it's assert
Harmon Rory is one of my favorite
directors yeah man and I saw him the
other day really and I was so afraid
yeah I met a guy
well somebody introduced me to somebody
through I met someone
yeah somebody introduced me to that
person and their name was harmony and it
really really looked like him but I was
so afraid to ask God he's so great gum
oh I think it's one of the great but
those films are so viscerally
provocative yeah and yeah always always
been provocative he's always been really
that's his thing and he gets on stage
and he'll talk [ __ ] about Jewish people
and he's Jewish
and he had the first thing I ever saw
she was depressed really almost yeah
yeah and the first thing I saw him in is
the amazing race' so yeah and so that
was so long ago but from the get-go he
was walking around like an Asian geisha
and just being like ladyship going back
to Africa
yeah right so it's like obviously the
guy is into like jarring types of you
really really pushing pushing pushing
the focus a lot of people had never seen
and you you get a whole new group we
never heard of Arya and this is how the
first time they hear about him so that's
an easy picking for a lame purr that's
the easy picking a hate you know it's
weird like oh I got to hate somebody
today this is the easiest the lowest
hanging fruit right I'm gonna hate him
but I think they probably also said you
know it's just that that was she be able
to say what he wants yeah I mean for
Kate said he should have known better
and I was like he did know just fine
like he knew that and and what I said to
him was it was like so how are you doing
you're fine right and
yeah you know you you realize you get
all this hatred all this stuff it's like
then you close the laptop and you look
around like birds are chirping I live in
New York it's beautiful outside so the
problem was is that his family and
you'll kind of think about this in the
context of the hate that he got he said
you know the problem was with my family
I realized oh they're taking this
seriously and it's on a national level
and so I had to say to them I'm okay
nobody's gonna kill me I'm being safe so
that's what's really interesting is
nobody really thinks behind all of that
online hatred is a family that is really
scared for their for their son her
brother yeah I think if the Knicks had
been doing better I think it would add
more support out of New York I'm serious
I love that but I do but yeah it was
just look we've all told jokes that have
bad timing you know like and sometimes
it's it you you should just be able to
joke like it and if you can joke and
turn off your Twitter and turn that off
if you don't care about that kind of
stuff then you still can I had to get
Google Alerts about yourself no I don't
and I I did for a long time because I
was just interested in what people had
to say a while ago I kind of got some
wild alerts to them man yeah but I I've
also had people I've got Googlers well
you don't have you written down in my
little yeah yeah yeah but I've had
people sort of say stuff like you know
you weren't funny in this movie or
you're terrible it almost feels like
they're talking about somebody else I
don't take that personally but I got to
a point where I I started understand
like it doesn't I still try and get on
Twitter interact with fans and do that
and I'm trying to interact more on
Instagram but the healthier thing if you
can do it is just to not you know just
to do Instagram when it feels like it's
fine and then that's my email it's
Google Alerts for Theo von that doesn't
come to your inbox yeah going on okay
sure I'll text a Nick and ask him home
okay yeah yeah yeah just gotta check in
my day is getting home at the end of the
day being like oh my god did I am i okay
and where hey yeah like getting inside
me like I'm okay everything
yeah so you to it you have you have some
sort of would you call it sort of are
you an anxious person do you have some
anxiety you think net yeah it like kind
of a laid-back anxiety it's like a
feeling that everything could go away at
any moment which I guess causes anxiety
I feel like is what I get anxiety no I
think it's the easygoing anxiety but
I'll say that they're wrong Andy Warhol
was always afraid that it was all gonna
disappear one so then I'm its do with a
lot of artists you know yeah I don't
know where that comes from
there's thinking that everything's not
gonna be okay oh wait I doing it when
when I was young and stuff nobody ever
told me that everything's okay there was
never anybody in my life who's like just
saying hey everything's fine you know so
there was this narrative started in my
head that everything just wasn't okay
you know and so and so that's I think I
like oh it's just a strong swimmer
that's in my bowl is that you know just
that everything is not okay everything's
on--okay like I'll call people and like
everything is okay right like yeah
things okay man I think also Los Angeles
has done that to me alive yeah Los
Angeles is filled with sad anxiety I
also want to say I love the way that you
speak you have such an 80s synchronic
way of speaking when you say I've got
that's just swimming around in my bowl I
said I would never no one else except
for you would say it like that but it
makes perfect sense just like the fire
alarm analogy but Los Angeles has so
much status anxiety and there's none of
that in New York right I mean we really
we came back and Kate went to his
screening with a friend of hers and her
friend was clearly had this just the
status anxiety a little bit of
desperation to her energy now and we
hadn't seen her in a couple years and I
actually didn't feel it it goes pretty
well for me at the light I like the guys
Laugh Factory I'm like buddies with
Julia and Bobby Lee and stuff yeah
that's always nice oh yeah I've used
Sergio in if I did any side rooms and
kind of all hipster type rooms there's
just so much data things I it's
definitely like that's your world no no
and certainly not anymore because those
people have become the like woke kind of
I'll go out for you on Twitter that kind
of stuff that's so for me i I really
like the clubs here and
in Manhattan I will do bar shows
sometimes but I also just want to
perform for real people because that's
what you and I do on the road and so it
doesn't help us a lot to like like I
haven't even been to Brooklyn since I
moved to New York and I feel like that
now it's so we are so much more a
Manhattan energy and couple and I'm so
much more of Manhattan person to me
first of all going to Brooklyn to get to
Brooklyn do a show and come back I could
have done three shows in Manhattan so
what was the point of going to Brooklyn
and second of all the audience is in
Brooklyn that's not who I'm performing
for an Omaha Nebraska
nor is it who I'm performing for in
Portland or San Francisco or
Philadelphia right it's it is just
Brooklyn and I don't need any of the
Brooklyn cash yeah just a lot of judge
it's it's definitely a lot of judgment
comes out of some of those holes you
know I don't do the cellar right now in
part because that table has a lot of
status anxiety and people are thinking
about hey I got to I'm past the cellar
and I get a little bit of energy of you
know you don't you don't belong here yet
you haven't paid your dues or something
and no other clubs are like that
so I that's the only place I experience
status anxiety in New York City is in
the Comedy Cellar proper and everybody
else is nice to meet ya I didn't know
we're in there and God for all those
people are so nice to me but the younger
class if it's not one of the girls so I
get along with Nikki Glaser Rachel
Feinstein like there's I get along with
all they're like man almost though to
this yeah - and they're just cool
they're just like down-ass chick I just
love that and so I'm I think that more
and more I'm seeing that like if I stay
away from that table at the Comedy
Cellar and and and I don't play that
room but I'll play Village Underground
in the fat black pussycat i I don't
really come across any I don't come
across much saddest things I in
Manhattan and so that's really helped me
because I agree with you I think Los
Angeles can kind of make you think where
am i where am i compared to this person
we don't see anybody here you don't
connect you never like I know I'm a nice
person songs because I'll see someone in
the morning or anytime and
Euler place you run into more people hey
how are you how are you you share a
little bit of what's going on if they're
not doing well I can notice and say hey
what's you know what's happening how you
know yeah do something to be a part of
somebody's day so you have more of a
reflection of who you are
somebody can see if you're not doing
well whereas here you just get so it's
just it's built in a way that if you
don't make an extra an extra if you
don't try harder to like you gotta get
other make an extra effort yes effort
but then you then you can get you can
get stuck were you just looking at your
own reflection all this I think that's
right and you're in a car and to get
from this neighborhood this neighborhood
takes 20 minutes 30 minutes 45 minutes
and that's why we've always lived in
Hollywood because we have a place here
we're just like a little apartment and
it's in Hollywood so we walk a lot we
don't really Drive in Los and that's
nice I'd rather have somebody even throw
[ __ ] at me just because somebody's
around you know yeah yeah it's getting
wild out here who's getting wild
Hollywood is it's a sketchy grimy place
but it was the closest thing we had to
New York City and so we've kind of stuck
around that area but yeah I I almost
crave right when I took Kate I was upset
that I had to take a car out here right
away because I just will walk I walk so
much out there and there's all these
secret stairs and stuff and that just
reminds you that Los Angeles isn't just
Hollywood the machine it's also a city
and we we drove from San Jose I have a
classic car it's in 1992 Mitsubishi
3000gt VR four twin turbo you bring it
up praise good it's red praise the Lord
PTL baby and and so we took that from
San Jose down the Pacific Coast one the
the highway 1 through Carmel and Big Sur
and then all the way down to Santa
Barbara jerk-off in the trunk of that
thing yeah you know wouldn't tell a soul
boy you feel me dude I wonder
is that you right there buy it over in
that in that field over there on the
right a little lower
do you have it in your Instagram
possibly yeah definitely right is that
feel like that Instagram you saw it but
it's no to the right a little up up left
nope field look at that field man oh
that's you it's on my Instagram yes
that's me but from transformers 4 that's
not my car do you got that you got a
little bit of thick and your baby yeah
you know what it is yeah dude you got to
get a thong baby got to go to Miami yeah
that's the way but yeah so we drove that
down the coast because we wanted to
remind ourselves that Los Angeles is not
is not California yeah the the that for
us that California isn't Los Angeles Los
Angeles is just a part of California and
huge man that was really really
important and we had such a good time
and we you know we renewed our vows and
Big Sur a while ago and we love Santa
Barbara so we got much more into the
everything even if you get out like you
know there's a podcast that I've done a
few times that I absolutely love and I
want to go do it again and it's called
on me it would be pretty recently it
would be like within the last month or
so Kate and I would have been out and
about that picture of me with the face
on my chest with Kate oh yeah that's me
that's pretty perfect mm-hmm that was
from the Critics Choice Awards we did an
opener with whistling bellybuttons so
yeah it would have been if you live in
just a few more down do you get nerve do
you what is your relationship like with
the media like you trust the media like
you because you've had some you know
you've had some wild stories via the
Amtrak experience the reason is is
because of the clickbait they're looking
for sort of the clickbait of it all and
when it is there it is that's it so
that's yeah you can play the cars here
I'll show you the car yeah that's it I
mean yeah right
isn't that nice yeah then that's the guy
smoking weed and a bus that's what it's
like - oh yeah Northern California the
bus isn't in use though but yeah
yeah I mean he was using him to get high
for sure but no I mean I you can't and
it's so sad that the the current
narrative is kind of true that they'll
just they'll either lie about you or
they'll turn whatever it is into
clickbait and they're kind of you know
it's that's the problem with the media
right now is they're they're trying to
get ratings like entertainment like a
television show or you know or movie
with the box office that type of thing
and so I try and really all you can do
is tune that out I asked Jennifer
Aniston about this in office Christmas
party I said how do you deal with the
tabloid stuff I'm and it's just so crazy
there just seems such a team that's able
to manage it so much well but they're
just lying I mean you on the front of
these things they say Oh Brad and and
and you know they're getting back
together or like Jennifer Aniston is so
happy that Brad and Angelina are getting
divorced and she was like I'm not happy
I want people to be happy I'm not happy
to assume that none of that is true I
said so how you deal with it she said
you know you just have to tune it out
and just have to be Zen about you have
to and it takes a lot of energy and it
requires a lot of work and you got to
know that the people that really know
you know the real story and the rest of
the world is gonna have to decide if
they want to believe these sources that
just aren't real you know when you had
can I ask you about the Train experience
thing only because we're still do you
really get to meet the FBI it's not it's
not as it's not as glamorous it's all
that yeah but you with that that case
hasn't been resolved yet because it was
a minute as I say it's a
miscommunication with the federal
government yeah and so and so once the
case is resolved they'll be able to talk
about it more but that's an example of
something that was like that was between
me and the government you know me trying
to if you see something say something
and the government worrying that it
wasn't anything and then TMZ just
immediately was like he did this and it
was false and he called it as a check
and it's like and there's no rebuttal
for people if there is something that
said that's all about them are wrong
there's no I have a
about that that you can't you're totally
the media can lie value with any
repercussion or any recourse and you
can't do anything you can't even sue
people for defamation if you're famous
so the second that they can prove that
in some arena you are famous you're
definitely famous and so if somebody
could say something terrible about you
in the press and you'd be like that's al
I'm suing for defamation they would they
would be able to say no that's not the
case and and they could sue you right
for something that isn't true and most
likely the lawyers would say theö it's
better to settle this out of court and
you could say but this person is lying
like this is what happened to me this
person is just lying you just decided to
lie and the lawyer will say well we
actually know from running his past that
he is a he has a history of suing
companies and people and settling out of
court so he's done this before and it's
better for you to pay him money than to
go in front of a court and possibly yeah
yes yeah more money and not only is that
a terrible reality what's also terrible
is now when it says that was settled out
of court
the public is kind of like so did he do
something wrong and just pay the person
off I just like that yeah they just
leave this this untethered end like kind
of or whatever crazy do you think but
but it then but doesn't it scare you to
work in an industry that's kind of built
on a lot of that like that absolutely
well I think that's a big part of right
now I'm doing stand-up and doing in in
doing stand-up I'm actually in a lot of
ways doing much better than I was doing
when I was on a television show because
financially it's the same if not better
artistically you're in charge of your
own everything in terms of like personal
life I have much more flexibility and I
get to spend a lot more time with Kate
but I'm doing a TV show or movie movie
I'm gone for three months and Kate
really can't visit me because she has
her own work and I can't go on the
weekends to visit her so I see her a lot
more doing stand-up than I would if I
was doing film and television but like
with the drew Barrymore movie I still
love doing films and but yeah it's a
it's stand-up is very different bill
burr
is a really good Conan interview Avicii
NARS with him no I mean yeah he's great
but he said the way you do it is don't
have your own show and which is funny
because he has f is for family but he
was like the best thing you can do is
just not have your own show then you can
say whatever you want because they can't
take anything away from me right and so
that's I think what was really pounded
into my face is that Hollywood almost
darkly prides itself on the fact that it
can take everything away from you to
every moment that's in fact what the
standin is about drew Barrymore plays a
movie star and her own stand and she's
playing two parts and it's about how
Hollywood loves to take everything away
from tear you down and then make you
crawl to pull yourself back up and do an
apology tour and apologize and say
please you know I want to apologize to
my fans I took slavery on are so not a
slavery there's no it's like a slavery
it's like they you know they can beat
you and then make you apologize for
making them beat you
yeah sort of kind of like that and that
is this way yeah like oh I understood
why you beat me yeah and I want to
apologize to you for and please give me
a chance to not be beaten yeah it's
almost like that and so stand-up just
eliminates that possibility what seemed
like such a I mean cuz you're such a I
mean you're just very different you know
and you and it's hard probably to fit I
would imagine I couldn't imagine being
I'm did you and fitting into because a
lot of things are very systematic the
world we live in is there's a lot of
systems that work best because it
facilitates all these moving people at
once and I think that's a good point
there is a component of me that doesn't
fit in very well to predispose systems
whether that be any kind of I mean
really any kind of system whether that
be like the rules at a theme park or you
know the school system I had a real
tough problem with that and the
Hollywood system I think for a long time
is not really known what to do with me
especially because I'm
self permis professed comedian na actor
right so yeah but you say that before
when I left Silicon Valley they didn't
understand they're like what are you
doing and I was like I just think this
is a really funny ending to it if I sort
of go off in this opium den and I think
this is a good time for me to sort of
and the series or in my part of series
and then the series can change and grow
and they're like but okay do you want to
come back and do three out of ten
episodes cuz HBO is super cool they were
like you want to come back and do three
out of the eight episodes were and I
said no no I think it's really funny to
end it just like this on this and this
four seasons is great that was great
thank you and they're like well what
about the season finale I was like no
that's okay
and they're like just you're not even
open and sees and what it was is they
were like but you're an actor and you're
on a successful television show this is
what every actor always dreamed of so
you how can you walk away from that and
it's like because I'm not an actor you
don't mean isn't my dream to be Erlich
on Silicon Valley it was my dream to
work with Mike judge and make a
television show that people loved or be
a part of one for sure but I also have
made television shows like core burger
or mash up the people of love I do
stand-up which I really love and I make
films that people love so it was kind of
like I don't want to and so that's an
example of Hollywood itself being like I
don't like this guy doesn't give a [ __ ]
or is he really act like he's he an
arrogant [ __ ] or is he truly a
nihilist what what is really going on
with this person so I can be very
confusing to those systems and I think
that's why I thrive in kind of
independent projects
stand up being the most important film
being sort of a capsule that happens it
goes out and then I'm on to the next
thing I'm not sort of on a television
show for years and years and why I
respect people like you who sort of have
done this which is to create your own
system and your own kind of and then
you've thrived from that and then that
becomes theaters you know and selling
out clubs and stuff like that so that
that and I'm think I'm also drawn to
stand-up comics because they usually
don't
necessarily fit in any system they're
not willing to fall in line yeah yeah
you know I think that's something uh
yeah I never I never wanted to if
something wasn't unique I never wanted
to do it or probably and you didn't want
to be a part of it necessarily yeah I've
had a tough time being a part of things
yeah because I think in nature I never
felt a part of things so then why would
I naturally easily I would it would be
tough to gravitate towards it sometimes
you know um but you know I think it's
interesting what you're saying man I
mean I think yeah burr does a great job
of it in the sense that he does stand up
he created an animation he kind of jumps
into things here and there but there's
nothing that's like keeping him in a
stable and a tether constantly yeah he's
not tethered at all and he's pretty
strongly a stand-up yeah he really is
and that's been another interesting
thing is to interact with people because
so many stand-ups that I know really
wanted to act you know I don't know how
well you want you want to succeed and
there's this there's this thing that
like that Hollywood is the success
there's this thing especially even with
our parents our generation I mean I
think I'm allotted in you but where they
television is it like I could - around
the world doing comedy but they're like
oh if I didn't see on an episode of
Everybody Loves Raymond are you doing
okay or what's going on - you're
homosexual yeah keep but it is you'll
get the in the beginning your career
you're like I'm headlining what was it I
was like I was in a movie as in
Cloverfield and I was in oh yeah yeah
and then I was I was headlining clubs
I'd been on a television show but got
canceled then I went to a family reunion
and somebody was like hey just keep at
it you'll make it one day and I was like
what I already did it
yeah what do you want you're gonna get
there I'm there over there it's
currently out right exact over to this
one sunset what do I need to do it's
currently happening so people do think
that and I've seen stand-ups who just
wanted to from stand-up to become a
television star our movie star whatever
talk show host and that just hasn't been
my end-all be-all and I'm so happy I'm
doing an international tour
you find the tickets on TJ Miller does
not have a website comm we're announcing
the tour very soon in May and June and
I'm going all over Europe and then and
then on to like other parts Auckland New
Zealand it's yeah and so that's so
exciting for me and I'm almost as
certainly as happy but almost happier
doing that than being on the cover of a
magazine because I'm on a hit television
show or I'm part of a big movie
franchise or something like that so
obviously I feel hashtag blessed for
both or for all of it but I don't really
think success is in success for me in a
lot of ways this is less in what you get
and more in how much control you have I
think you're really successful if you
have control of your own life
and you're not you know that's why I
feel bad for a lot of actors because
they have to take actually after Tiger
belly Bobbie Lee and I were talking and
he just said he said are we so lucky TJ
and I was like yeah and he's like you
know to have comedy and I said oh yeah
definitely goes we're just so lucky we
just get to tour and make money and do
this thing and it's so fun I just were
so lucky and he was talking about we
both were kind of talking about if
you're an actor then the job ends and
you kind of are waiting for the next job
and you know we're talking about not in
that you with stand-up this this is
never gonna stop until you want it to so
having that control that's to me that
success being you know really really
rich because you were the guy the one of
the Nerds and the Big Bang Theory I
don't know that that is you didn't have
a lot of say in your life during that
time and I I don't know how much money
is that's worth to sort of relinquish
that much control I would much prefer to
not make as much oh it's nothing about
Silicon Valley like don't you want to be
rich I mean say that it's sort of like
oh it always a bottom line of all of it
don't you want to don't you want to do
that yeah don't you want to be able to
buy a boat
big house but you wanna have a second
wife Yeah right divorce be able to pay
the alimony and I you know I kind of was
like no I don't want a boat I don't need
a I want to live in New York City and so
we have this dope place in New York City
and I don't need a pool and I don't need
a plane one of the guys from Silicon
Valley bought a plane Wow
like what likes to fly planes and stuff
but I was like I just want to be a comic
in New York that was the coolest thing
to me it's not like having a mansion in
Bel Air or something is it addictive
though whenever you get because you
found me you
I remember seeing when you did the UM
the Yogi Berra edition right that was
yeah yeah yeah I think and I was so
jealous I remember seeing like man this
guy he just so it's for Allison Jones I
think he did it for was that right yeah
totally matter that because you did a
special audition right you did a special
audition where this is what I heard this
is just from okay this guy found a bear
somewhere and got to go win and did a
special edition next to a very dangerous
bear
yeah and got a really good take and
submitted the and submitted that as the
audition and said you should be a part
of this so the truth is I went and I
audition because I thought it would be
funny to be in Yogi Bear 3d hmm because
it would be a funny stand-up credit
right mm-hm
and it would just be silly to do that
and then I kind of on a ferris was gonna
be in and I was like oh my god that
would be amazing because she's like one
of my comedy idols and then I went and I
do the audition with Allison Jones it
went well
and then I went and I bought a Ranger
hat as a joke and I went in and I I went
in and I was like hey I just wanted to
look late cuz I brought my own Ranger
hat and I was just wondering if I could
use it I don't have to but it was $19.99
and you know I can't return it I can
exchange it for something else but I
bought it for the audition and they were
kind of like yeah that's fine man I was
like great and I put the I put on the
Hat and they say say your name and slate
you know the poor kid in the casting
system that's got the camera say her
name is Slade my joke with that is I'm
always like TJ Miller auditioning for
the role of Yogi Berra 3d I'm 6 foot 3
but when I act like crouch so I'm 6 foot
2 and then they're like okay we're ready
and then I go I'm sorry can I just stop
you guys real quick and there's this
poor casting since I just ask you
something how much about how much head
room do I have because I'm gonna be
doing a lot of hat work so if you can
give me sort of enough so think of it
less is head room more hat room it's how
much hat room do I have and this kid's
like I mean I don't know like about this
much I was like yeah but I can't that's
smaller to me than it is to you because
you're far away so just tell me when to
stop
and I was like and he's like he's like
no no stop before there I was like can
you get can you give me this what about
here ok cuz I'm gonna be doing kind of
like that sort of stuff so do I have
room to do that in this kids like yeah
sure they're already cracked so now
you've already got a lot of humor going
before the auditions already yeah that's
a key bro he hasn't gone so then Alison
texted me actually out for the audition
she was like you know there you're their
first choice and I think this is you're
gonna get good news tomorrow and I was
like tell them that I want to submit
supplemental materials to give them a
better idea of what I would do with the
part she was like I don't think he need
to and I was like yeah but I have this
great idea so that I did I when I rented
a bear at the Hollywood animals oh
really I feel like and then I made it
send it to them and you have it was a
joke the whole thing is right I get it
but still as a resident as somebody that
auditions stuff that would feel like
suck to a regular person yeah for the
full lobe yeah because you're like
already have like I'm just be like I'm
gonna I'm just 3/4 low bad guys and
yeah I wasn't full loving it no way and
so high I sent them this audition
because you gotta think about if I've
already gotten it and then I make a
funny video like that's not gonna hurt
the situation so I sent it and they
watched it I thought it's so funny and
they sent all the way up to alan horne
who was the head of the studio at the
time jewish hire or not he I'm not sure
but I think I met him he warned he he
goes yeah he's been I think he's the
head of he was the head of Warner
Brothers and now he's the head of he's
involved in Disney somehow and he he
never laughs at anything and he watched
this good and he didn't laugh but he was
like we should we should hire this kid
he's really really funny and I said well
yeah he was he was our first choice so I
did that movie yeah 2010 and that's the
film that right afterwards my actually
while I was in the film my brain
hemorrhage just slightly [ __ ] yeah and I
started to go actually insane like
clinically insane because there was just
too much blood in my brain and then when
I came back afterwards I was in like a
really crazy state and I am that's when
I had the seizures plural and went to
the hospital they're like we need to
operate on your plan
yogi birdie brings it all around full
circle that's amazing coast to coast and
worldwide
[Music]
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself on my
[Music]
[Music]